[Music]
whoa hey everybody how's it going
I'm incredibly thrilled to be here and
I'm just I know you're waiting for the
next speaker but I just want to couple
quick minutes about Rhys
I met Patti last year he came through
town and he asked me to be the co-host
for Rhys and I didn't know what to
expect and as you can see here this is
your first web summit the team behind
this conference are just incredible and
experience in Hongkong was just as
magical and very exciting it's probably
the best conference you'll ever see in
Asia so if you're interested in the
Asian market please come and join me in
July next year I will personally buy
everybody some dim sum if you actually
show up we can have a big young child
table together and then check it out
it's just going to be the 20th
anniversary of the handover in Hong Kong
so the city is going through a nice
polishing so it should be very exciting
for you to come out and check it out
I've been working with startups for many
many years in Hong Kong and having rise
it based out of Hong Kong but a global
conference has been very exciting for
the community there and to this Turing
Web Summit I was able to bring along
people from China Japan Hong Kong
Singapore as well to be my guest here so
I'm very excited about that if you want
to learn more about it don't meet me on
there's a Rhys lounge over in Pavilion
one just behind the stadium here and be
great to see you guys in July 2017 thank
you very much
so it's my great pleasure and great
honor to introduce the next speaker I'm
sure everybody's seen his snapchats read
his books and just follow this guy this
guy is an incredible amount of energy
and support for entrepreneurs and
founders and I'd like to call my new
best friend I just met him backstage
like two minutes ago for the first time
but maybe he maybe found a connection to
me so we're together but please put your
hands together and welcome to the stage
the CEO of vaynermedia Gary Vaynerchuk
[Music]
what up Lisbon shit's changing
communication is changing the attention
of our consumer is changing people are
baffled by results of elections and
business growth and turnouts like this
but I am NOT because for my whole life
since I was six years old putting up
signs on trees and poles to sell my
lemonade
I've been day trading attention we're
living through regardless of what the
media or your social media tells you we
are living through the greatest era to
be an entrepreneur or human ever let's
clap that [ __ ] up because it's true the
problem is we especially if you came to
this conference especially if you're
[ __ ] a teenager back there we yeah we
have a massive responsibility to start
making positivity louder one of the
trends that I'm massively fascinated by
is the minority of angry is much louder
than the silent majority of happy and if
I can accomplish anything and I'll get
into my real talk in a second but if I
can accomplish anything at this
conference I ask that the people that
are as happy as I am because I'm the
most grateful [ __ ] you will ever meet
for them to get louder about how good it
actually is
how many people are entrepreneurs or in
a start-up raise your hand very nice how
many people work in companies and
organizations raise your hands very nice
let's break them down into two things
the two things that are broken
which means there's opportunity and
those two sectors look like the
following let's start with the
entrepreneurs as positive as I am we are
also living through one of the worst
eras of entrepreneurship let me explain
we are living through especially over
the last five years the greatest era of
fake entrepreneurship entrepreneurship
has gotten so popular so cool that
people that never sold anything or
aspire to build a business have now
decided that they are entrepreneurs
because they came up with the uber for
delivering oranges to your [ __ ] house
this is yeah you should clap that [ __ ]
up because it's a problem and let me
explain why one of the things that I
feel a huge responsibility for because
I'm such a proponent of entrepreneurship
is to also talk about the practical
nature of entrepreneurship there's an
underlining thing going on in the
Silicon Valley ecosystem that hits the
entire world which is we are seeing very
quiet underlying suicide in our space
because there are people who are not
equipped to be entrepreneurs because let
me tell you what entrepreneurs do they
get punched in the [ __ ] face 24/7 365
for the rest of their lives and if you
were built for that if you went to good
schools or mommy and daddy protected you
in an ecosystem and you come out with
your product selling oranges and the
market punches you in the face you are
not prepared for that and so what we
mean to more than anything whether
you're an entrepreneur whether you're a
kid growing up whether you are an
executive one of the things we have to
start deploying and talking about more
in this eco chamber is self-awareness
you have to know who you are
not everybody has to be a
one for every Instagram that made a
billion dollars in 500 days there's five
million instace shits that aren't going
to win number 39 at snapchat and number
78 executive at Facebook are going to
make a lot more money than the number
ones in this room on a company that
isn't going to succeed so please don't
listen to me or [ __ ] Patti or anybody
else if you are not an entrepreneur that
is phenomenal [ __ ] to be very frank with
you I wish I wasn't self-awareness
corporate people that work in
organizations companies one more time
all right you guys have a whole nother
thing going on over the last seven years
I've built a company called vaynermedia
with my homie Matt Higgins Matt Higgins
where are you gotta be summer anyway
Maddie's in the crowd we've gone from
three to 750 people three to a hundred
million in revenue Under Armor chase
Unilever Turner biggest brands in the
world and I've been fascinated coming
from growing my family liquor business
coming from investing in things like
Twitter and Tumblr and things of that
nature coming from that ecosystem I
didn't understand what was going on in
your world I didn't get it I didn't
realize why you were spending so much
money on television and print and
outdoor I didn't get it but now I've
come to learn it and what's really
interesting to me is the massive naivete
I had a very interesting election night
as an American born in the Soviet Union
I was flying to London over the election
so I didn't actually see it I landed and
got all of it at once the 50,000 texts
from friends and family the actual news
of the results but interestingly enough
more than anything what caught my
attention because I was a little less
naive than the marketplace of what could
have happened that night was the
business aspect of that day the amount
of CEOs and CMOS that called me or
emailed me or wrote me an email that
said huh maybe you're right about this
TV thing or this mainstream media we
have an enormous
and I mean enormous over estimation of
what mainstream media and traditional
communication platforms are worth and a
gross underestimate
of what's happening in the worlds that
we're all looking at there are hundreds
of people right here right now filming
live that technology would have cost
thousands of dollars on a big [ __ ]
camera like this just ten years ago we
are living through my friends if you
understand anything about what's going
on while we sit here in Lisbon we are
living through the greatest shift in
human communication since the printing
press communication has been completely
shifted forever there are 60 year-old
men in this audience who texted poop
emojis last night though watch this I'm
going to show you something really
fascinating do me a favor Web Summit I
want you to stand up if the following
statement is true I know some of you are
[ __ ] lazy but it's good circulation
so if this is true to you stand up how
many people here now actually get upset
when another human being
calls them stand up gonna wait
I want everybody don't sit down yet I
want everybody look at this these are
human beings I'm gonna repeat it to
everybody these are human beings that
actually get upset when another person
calls them the main way we're old just
five or six years ago let's clap it up
for these pioneers I'll tell you why I'm
clapping for that pioneer right there
I'm clapping because what these people
haven't innately
felt and understood is the emergence of
the most important asset in our new
ecosystem along with the health of our
family money our religion and the health
which is time the reason those people
stood up and were mad that somebody
called them is because we have
technology now that allows us to
actually text somebody and I'll call you
back on my time don't call me on your
time like literally like [ __ ] I'll
text you back mom that kind of [ __ ] and
so we as business people in corporate
America need to wrap our head around one
very big truth the day of advertising
stealing somebody's time is over and
when I say over I don't mean it's dead
people will still run radio in between
the songs that you want to hear people
will run lots of commercials in between
the sports and the TV shows that you
watch you'll be reading a very nice
article and the next page will have a
big [ __ ] car ad on it and you'll have
to go seven more pages you'll go to a
nice little website and a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] pop-up banner ad will go in your
[ __ ] face and by the way let's talk
about pop-ups real quick the next time I
get a pop-up I mean this is so
devastating pop up some cell phones I
don't know if you guys are living the
same life I am but when I get a pop up
on a cell phone with such little real
estate and that little ex is so goddamn
small and you know what happens our
thumbs are [ __ ] fat as [ __ ] and so
when you click it you click into the ad
you don't actually click out and they
just stole seven of my seconds
and I want my seven seconds how many
people work at advertising agencies
raise your hand
hi me too great so back at our
advertising agencies as you know we look
at Dayton were like oh my god
look at the six point seven percent
click-through ratio because nobody can
[ __ ] X those piece-of-shit ads so to
count people like yeah awesome we're
[ __ ] awesome meanwhile the person on
the other end is like I am never buying
another Samsung product for the rest of
my [ __ ] life it is time that we
understand that not all impressions are
equal you can make a bad impression not
all press is good press regardless of
what you're thinking right now and so
there are so many macro trends eighty
billion dollars spent on television and
there's not enough you want to see
something crazier than the standing up
by show of hands how many people here
now watch television outside of live
sports not when that TV show airs but on
DVR TiVo whatever your country's version
of that is or Netflix HBO GO how many
people now watch television on their
time not when the show airs raise your
hand
raise it high a weird all 12,000 of you
and how many people here when given the
option fast forward every single
commercial raise your hands go figure
everybody and even if those brands that
are spending 80 billion dollars to sell
you some [ __ ] soap get lucky because
I don't know your remote control fell
off your [ __ ] bed every person here
when that happens grabs this and
comments on what they just saw or checks
their email my friends it is about
attention
it is about attention the way we have
the storyteller is predicated on tension
I'm sad that Twitter's not the number
one social network I spent all and some
of you know this I spent all of 2009
through 2012 spending 15 hours a day
replying to every [ __ ] person on
Twitter I was the 30th most violent
person I'm
add that it doesn't have everybody's
attention anymore
but I did not do what so many people do
in this room and start crying and
dwelling and hoping that it held on I
started understanding what was happening
on snapchat and Instagram and sometimes
I figured out what was going on on vine
and Socialcam and they may not be around
anymore but the fact that so many in
this room are scared to take the risk to
learn new platforms because they might
not be here in a couple weeks or a
couple years without realizing that only
once do you have to actually buy the
beachfront property on the most
important platform and you make all your
time our way possible is wild to make
you have to wrap your heads around in
this entire room that this is now the
television and the television is now the
radio and Facebook and Instagram and
snapchat are ABC NBC BBC and Sky and
whether you're a startup or a b2b
company or a entrepreneur or a
corporation you need to figure out how
to make the best shows on those networks
[Applause]
there's something I said in a video on
my youtube channel that really has just
continued to strike and so I want to
share it it's probably the most tangible
thing that I can leave you with at this
conference that I want to give it to you
a lot of people here that spiel that I
just said a lot of people realize that
I've spent a lot of years advertising
creating content and nothing nothing
Trump's building a brand there's a lot
of digital marketers in here that
understand quantum version they're
mathematicians and that's phenomenal I
love math but marketing is not math it's
a mix of math and art used to be a whole
lot more art it's a lot more math that
makes me happy I love when art and math
have a kid and it's the greatest thing
right that's where we're in right now
that's why so many people struggle some
of you are really artsy fartsy and love
them creative and want it all subjective
about the color of the [ __ ] teal
shirt and other of you love math so much
you can't look anybody in the goddamn
[ __ ] face
you think it's all math and you don't
give a [ __ ] about what's on the other
end of it you're both wrong it's a
combination of the two
the reason Facebook is such a big
platform and the reason Facebook as we
sit here outside of Russia and China is
the number one platform for every single
person here to sell [ __ ] regardless of
age and demo b2b or b2c is because it is
the one platform that combines the two
and a scale that we've never seen but
creative is the variable if I came up
here today I've got the attention I've
got the attention right now but if this
keynote sucks for you I did not convert
and if it did it did and so creative my
friends is the variable of success
what's important about that is people
are crippled by the creation of you're
sitting right now and thinking but what
am I going to make I'm not as handsome
and charismatic as Garry what am I going
to do what am I gonna do
and so so there was something I said to
a kid and there's so many of you that
are so smart and get this you realize
making videos on Instagram and Facebook
can change your business you realize
writing articles on medium and Linkedin
can change your business
but you're stuck you don't know what to
say and so I will tell you what I'm most
I'm you know it's funny I'm building it
up because I'm building up for myself
because I know in two or three years
like many other talks I'll get emails
from many of you saying this was the
thing and so I'm excited some building
up the drama for myself what I said to
the kid was and he was stuck I said look
the problem is everybody and everybody
in this room is trying to create content
if you can make this slight shift in
your head tonight we've got a real shot
which is the following I believe that
all the upside over the next decade in
storytelling in a mobile-first
environment driven by video is
predicated on documenting not creating
if you understand that you could just
talk about your meetings or picking up
oranges from that [ __ ] app or
whatever it may be that documenting the
journey there they're actually startups
in this room who are totally [ __ ]
they're not good enough
their ideas straight [ __ ] they will go
out of business however if those two
entrepreneurs Karen and Rick actually
documented their daily journey of trying
to buy the business or build the
business they would actually have other
people eventually if they're good enough
interesting enough they would have other
executives and entrepreneurs actually
watch that journey and maybe lead to an
AK you hire for talent maybe an
acquisition and if nothing else more
leverage for a job after the aftermath
we need to start documenting we are all
media companies we have it right in our
hand we're shy we're scared we're
worried about what other people going to
think fear is not an option if you've
raised your hand for entrepreneurship
fear is not an option I prefer to lose I
sometimes secretly hope that my
companies go out of business to zero I
lose everything all of you write things
on social media that I actually suck
them was full of [ __ ] and then in the
dirt with a [ __ ] the pain I'm gonna
rise like a [ __ ] phoenix and kill all
you [ __ ]
I mean it yeah I mean it if you do not
have that or some version of that in
your stomach then find somebody to work
for that does because we've lived
through seven to eight unbelievable
years of economic bliss if you think
this [ __ ] lasts forever
you're either super [ __ ] young clap
it up for the youngsters one more time
they don't [ __ ] know they're like
seven the last time [ __ ] was bad or you
forgot you don't want to deal in reality
all my friends talking about all these
changes and brexit and presidential you
have to deal with the reality of the
situation
dwelling and pondering and crying
doesn't do [ __ ] and it especially
doesn't do [ __ ] in this eco chamber in
this arena there is no crying you can
cry you're just gonna lose and I bad
news about complaining and crying let me
tell you something about complaining and
crying that's really really gonna hurt
for all you complainers out there nobody
gives a [ __ ] and let me give you a
preview who gives a [ __ ] the following
people give a [ __ ] when you complain the
other losers around you you're sick
broken parent that secretly wants to
hold you down so that you're not more
successful than them and let me remind
you one more time the other [ __ ]
losers around you so here we are heading
into 2017 people are asking all sorts of
questions we still clearly are close or
it has to happen sooner than later
economic crush many people here rich on
paper go talk to a lot of 40 to 50 year
olds that were rich on paper during web
1.0 back in 99 2000 2001 it's sitting
its flustering it's here it's upon us
and now we have to more than ever we
have to start deploying self-awareness
if you leave here and start your process
of really knowing what makes you happy
of who are you really
if you could stop chipping away the
voices from the outside if you can start
figuring out what you're scared of if
you want to actually do something even
in the light of the picture that I'm
painting right now who are you scared to
fail in front of the reason so many of
you are not doing what you want to do is
you're scared to fail in some you're
scared that your brother will judge you
your wife your girlfriend your husband
and most scary your mom or your dad you
need to eliminate that and your own that
fear and put yourself in a position to
succeed because with all of this with
all of this we are now in the greatest
era for the first time ever with no
[ __ ] money with no goddamn
connections this can put you on the map
if you're good enough if you are good
enough to be up here to make bling bling
if you are good enough nobody's stopping
you not [ __ ] Donald Trump not the
[ __ ] Russians nobody if you are a
minority if you are a female if you are
transgender if you're a [ __ ] alien
the market doesn't give a [ __ ] if you
make the best [ __ ] you will win
do you know sucky it was to be a nerd 20
years ago but now the market is
rewarding [ __ ] nerds and now they're
rock stars clap it up if you're a
[ __ ] nerd
the best part about that was so some
dude was clapping for it I say clapping
of him [ __ ] heard he was like sauce I
don't know I don't know I'm so grateful
I was born in the Soviet Union both of
my grandfather's spent ten years in jail
for being Jewish right like more people
in America died last year because a
coconut fell off a tree and hit him in
the head then from terrorism I'm just
gonna say that one more time yeah true
funny thing about data it doesn't
[ __ ] lie more Americans died last
year because a coconut fell from a tree
hit them on the head they die then
terrorism as somebody who aspires to be
one of the great Brander and marketers
of his generation
I refuse for hate and horseshit and
negativity to out mark at me I will sit
here today I will sit here on the slides
on every one of those platforms when
they put it up I hope they do follow me
back there you told me you would thank
you very much on stage on those
platforms every day 24/7 365 I will
remind you that life is phenomenal that
nobody gives a [ __ ] so the government or
your mommy's not going to help you
you've got to do it on your [ __ ] but
it's never been better
we've got a bigger chance than ever we
can do our thing and so I flew from
London I just flew in I've barely
[ __ ] made it to this talk all the
[ __ ] guards here are [ __ ]
gangsters right [ __ ] those guards
I barely made it here and I don't know
I've got some other talk now for 45
minutes about marketing on another stage
and then I'm flying home and the only
reason I wanted to be here
the only reason I wanted to be in Lisbon
for four hours today is because I knew
there was a lot of you I knew there was
a lot of youngsters and we are choosing
what to listen to on social media now so
we're going into what we want to hear
and a lot of people need to hear one of
two things today which is this is the
greatest era to ever be alive and be an
entrepreneur executive if you want it
and stop complaining and dwelling cuz
nobody gives a [ __ ]
thank you yes Oakland ah can you imagine
[Applause]
you